hey everyone i'm
sharmly and i welcome you all to this
new video of simply learn
on a very interesting crypto solana in
this
video we will explore some of the
interesting
and important aspects of solana crypto
first we will understand what is solana
then we will look into what is a soul
token
or sol token
then we will explore when and how did it
originated
after which we will look into some of
the features of solana
then we will explore what type of
consensus method
does solana use
after which we will understand how
solana works
then we will explore the current price
and volume of solana in today's date
after that we will look into the future
of solana
holds for itself and at last
we will look into real-life uses of
celana
so without doing much ado let's start
the video
let's explore what is solana
solana is a cryptocurrency that is used
to pay for transactions
or a decentralized computing network
solana attempts to increase blockchain
scalability
by combining proof of stake and proof of
history consensus
as a result solana promises to be
capable of processing 50 000
transactions
per second while maintaining
decentralization
now the question arises what is the sl
token
or soul token sonata's ecosystem uses
the sl token
as its native currency as a result the
token can be transferred between nodes
in the solana cluster in exchange for
running
on-chain programs or certifying their
results
it can also be used to make micro
payments known as lamp ports
now when we are talking so much about
solana crypto
let's also dive down and explore how and
when
exactly it came into existence
anatoly yakovenko established the solana
platform in 2017.
before launching solana yakovenko
worked at balcom after working as a
software engineer at dropbox
he has a wide spectrum of knowledge with
compression methods
he developed a new method of dealing
with typical throughput difficulties in
the bitcoin
and ethereum blockchain with the help of
eric williams and solana cto
greg fitzgerald
they intended to develop a trustless
distributed protocol
with increased scalability the team now
has experience
from leading companies around the world
including apple
google microsoft intel twitter
dropbox and others
now that we know what solana is and all
about its background
let me ask you a question recently
solana joined hands with two foundations
to raise a fund
of 5 million dollars to encourage the
next wave of creators
and fans onto crypto networks so comment
down your answers in the comment section
below
to know the correct answer to this
question watch this video till the end
moving on let's talk about its features
which makes it unique and popular
scalable
solana uses proof of history and a
number of other
groundbreaking features to allow the
network to scale
at the rate of moore's law low cost
for applications with billions of users
solana is designed
to keep fees low so you will never have
to worry about
rising fees as your user base grows
composable the single global state of
solana
guarantees project composability
multiple shards and layer 2 systems
should never be dealt with
so we have heard a lot of references to
proof of history
but what exactly is it that we will
discuss within the type of consensus
method solana uses
the cilanna network which has 200
physically different nodes
can handle a throughput of more than 50
000 tps
when using gpus is one of the most
performant permissionless blockchain
unlike bitcoin which employs the proof
of work algorithm
as the system decentralized clock solana
uses the proof of history technique
you can use proof of history to
construct historical records
that verify an event occurred at a given
point in time
this algorithm is a verifiable delay
function with a high frequency
this function requires a specific number
of sequential steps
to evaluate each transaction or even
that is examined
will be assigned a unique hash an
account that can be verified publicly
and effectively the count serves as a
cryptographic timestamp
allowing us to determine when each
transaction or event occurred this
provides
increased throughput and efficiency
within the solana network
now that we know about its structure and
mechanism
let's explore how solana works
now we know solana has built a
one-of-a-kind method for determining the
time
of a transaction known as proof of
history
let's see the step-by-step procedure of
how it works
step one input the details of
transactions performed
in the network to its leader
step two leader will now efficiently
sequence
and organize the messages so that they
can be processed
by another nodes step 3
the leader then executes the
transactions based on the ram's current
state
step 4 the completed states transactions
and signature will then be published by
the leader
to the verifiers or replication nodes
step 5 if the state receives
confirmation
the verifiers will perform the same
transactions on their copies
of the state and publish their
signatures
and at last step 6 the consensus process
will then use
the published confirmations as votes now
that we know everything about solana
let's have a look at the price and
volume of solana according to market
capitalization
the solana network can process more than
50 000 transactions
in one second and the current price of
it
is 30 with a circulating volume of 270
million
sql coins which is quite impressive
considering
its time span in market capitalization
as well as compared to other
cryptocurrencies
let's see what future the solana holds
for itself
filana although being a new project has
delivered on its promises
of speed and scalability it's token
price has also done well attack
attracting investors attention
nonetheless the network acceptance and
usage
are still in the early stages we won't
know whether solana speed make a
significant difference in the bitcoin
realm
until we witness substantial traffic and
more use cases
having a fast network is beneficial but
the advantages
will only occur as more people utilize
it
and more use cases emerge real-life uses
of solana
serum radium bon peda orca
oxygen and phantom wallet are some of
the recent projects
that solana is working with well this is
all about solana crypto
but before ending this video i asked a
question before
in this video so the answer to the
question is
audience and metaplex foundation
solana joined hand with these foundation
on 23rd july
to raise funds and to promote the
participation of new creators in the
crypto network
we have almost reached the end of this
video if i missed anything important
do let me know in the comments section i
hope you enjoyed this video on solana
and learn something new from it if you
liked this video
then please do hit the like button
thanks for watching this video
and stay tuned for more updates and
videos from sipleto
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here